cae la tarde en la habana y las calles
ya están vacías los cubanos prefieren
anticiparse al toque de queda que
comienza en la noche
el gobierno decidió adoptar nuevas
medidas en la capital se prohíbe salir
entre las 21 horas y las 5 horas se
requiere permiso de circulación
obligatorio multa de 78 dólares en caso
de reuniones no usar máscara o salir a
la calle de manera injustificada para
este paramédico respetar las reglas es
un deber patriótico o que ya ha sido mal
manifestado y esto tiene que evitarlo
como nosotros mismos por los niños por
la institución por la repubblica agua
por la humanidad
los turistas ahora deben permanecer en
cuarentena al llegar a la isla los
vuelos desde países muy afectados como
méxico o eeuu son limitados para algunos
estas nuevas restricciones eran
inevitables ahora teniendo media página
de atún para evitar problemas cada
bocado lo gastaba así tantas rutas y
está muy bien la medida tomada pero
también hay que analizar también los
problemas también que uno tiene después
de una reapertura de las fronteras y una
relajación de medidas sanitarias el
virus se está propagando nuevamente
desde mediados de enero el país ha
contabilizado un promedio de 800 nuevos
pacientes por día
cuál ha puesto a toda la vacunación y
está desarrollando 4 vacunas es la única
nación latinoamericana que desarrolla
sus propias vacunas de ccoo y 19 la más
avanzada ya está en pruebas las
autoridades planean compartir su
producción con países en dificultad en
la carrera mundial por comprar dosis
sería otro ejemplo de la diplomacia
médica de la isla ya que despliega a
muchos médicos en el exterior